the new york jets have not nearly been
as good this year as some thought they
would be the expectations were much
higher than two and seven chris you and
i thought that between the bills and the
jets one of these two teams would become
contenders well the bills did the jets
didn't but the good news for adam gase
he's not on the hot seat according to
team chairman christopher johnson
christopher johnson said yesterday that
adam gase will not be fired either
during this season or after it said
christopher johnson it's the trust ic
seeing him work with sam darnold gives
me a lot of confidence seeing him work
with joe douglas the new gm of the team
it's a whole new dynamic in this
building it's a really positive dynamic
they have the same vision for this team
going forward there are a number of
reasons but those two really big ones
are why i feel
confident about adam being our head
coach going forward so look this doesn't
surprise me because again joe douglas
wasn't the best gm that they could find
as a result of exhaustive search where
it it took into account no factors other
than finding the best gm possible this
was a guy that adam gase wanted nothing
against joe douglas but this is a guy
adam gase wanted so
joe douglas isn't whispering to
christopher johnson we need a new head
coach douglas is there because of gays
he's working with gays they are working
hand in hand and they're trying to work
this out so it doesn't surprise me that
christopher johnson is on board with it
because joe douglas is on board with it
yeah and as long as joe douglas is on
board with it johnson's going to be on
board with it and they're all going to
be fine until woody johnson comes back
from the uk where he's the us ambassador
and fires everybody until then though i
think it's going to be joe douglas at
the gm and adam gase is the head coach i
i have no problem with this i don't you
know and again i know i we're i'm living
up here in the new york area and i know
jess fans are ready to like pop their
heads off and they're going crazy and
they don't want that vote of confidence
for adam gase at this point and things
like that i heard people here in the
building yesterday kind of ranting about
that and i understand but also you know
with adam gates specifically one hey he
he made some dolphins teams who weren't
very good very competitive the last two
years he went to playoffs with a team
down there in miami that wasn't that
talented and found a way to get them
into the playoffs there's something to
that other years they had other
disasters and he kept them competitive
now this year let's get into that okay
they probably had the first the the
toughest first seven games in all of
football schedule wise sam darnold gets
a mono cj mosley's out let alone he had
to deal with the crap that uh mc cagnan
had left over on that roster their
offensive line sucks i mean there's no
other way to say it there's no special
people on the defensive line as of right
now there are stupid bad signings in the
secondary from mccagnan and joe douglas
is there and i think joe douglas yeah
you're right part of the reason he's
there from adam gase but damn i think
he's also shown that like he was worthy
of that job and especially coming from
the ravens and the eagles two of the
teams we've seen that are more the
better built football teams over the
last 10 to 15 years so i i i think you
do stay the course here you got to at
least one more year you have to do that
the jets roster is crap and i think it's
proven this year let alone they've had
some unfortunate problems and injuries
and things like that
one of the things chris that
increasingly fascinates me about the nfl
the tension between
the business interests of a team from
january to august when you're trying to
create excitement so you can sell
tickets yeah and jerseys and just create
a sense that this year can be
the year and then the coaching staff
which does not want that bar to be set
unnecessarily high and i think the
coaching staff bought into the idea that
the jets are better than maybe their
circumstances and their schedule would
suggest and you know there were some
people who didn't like the fact that the
jets were in the 20s when we had power
rankings and yes folks as much as they
act like they don't pay attention they
pay attention
and you know right now this team would
be lucky to be in the range of 20 in the
nfl's overall power structure but i i
just think that these teams need to have
a better strategy for managing
expectations in the off-season you want
to sell tickets you want fans to be
motivated to make the financial
commitment to support the team but you
also don't want your customers to be
completely and totally upset with the
product that they get and uh and again
even even if the expectations had been
tempered two and seven is a season they
didn't expect but i think the mono the
sam darnold mono yes i think that i
think that he's still at some level
dealing with that too so you just don't
flip a switch and it's like you never
had mono it takes some time to get over
it which makes what he did against the
cowboys even more amazing no i yes that
you know and then cj mosley was the
quarterback of the defense so you got
two guys that are like the leaders of
both sides of the football that aren't
there for a significant amount of the
time that is tough and yeah i mean would
i have liked to seen some better
showings during that time yes definitely
would have uh but again i know i over
evaluated some of the things they've had
on the roster calachio assembly and some
of the things he's dealt with and that
fiasco i mean there's just a number of
things that are issues there all
together and i think you got to give
adam gase a chance here and joe douglas
a chance to build something in their
vision
and they need some difference makers
that's the biggest thing and they got
some money to play with you know so can
they get a pass rusher for the first
time since john abraham i mean can they
do some things like that in the
offseason you know that's going to be
the big thing like you're saying to sell
tickets to get the fan base re-energize
and things like that they need to find
two or three difference makers uh to
help the team out and help just the
perception of the team with the fans in
the new york area
what else they need to do chris from a
pr standpoint they need to work some of
the more prominent voices in the local
media a little bit better than they are
they've made some enemies because look
when macagnan gets fired to the extent
that mcagnen is someone who's providing
information and access to people in the
media and that's shut off now
you get people who are upset and you get
people who maybe have a little bit of a
vendetta and maybe would like to see the
house get clean so they would have
somebody in there that would give them
the information that makes it easier to
do their jobs that's part of the game
that these teams have to play if they
want to have a good relationship with
the media and in new york i think it's
important to have a good relationship
with the media well i agree i mean both
teams in new york i feel like are
fighting the media public perception uh
issue and and the jets yes you're right
that's a very valid point mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports